Pope Francis has had a real facility
with language when it comes to
responding to these allegations first he
says I won't respond
we know previously he's called young
traditional Catholics a too rigid he's
gone on and on about this and then he
when he called for the silence of his
accusers of the people who are
legitimately with with great credibility
I know that word has been abused these
days but our true vegan Oh does in fact
have credibility when they say that he
was complicit he knew about certain
abuses and he covered them up or he
promoted people who were doing them Pope
Francis's response to say well they
should be silent there's a silent and
prayerful which is a very nice way of
saying shut up in your face I mean that
is what he's telling the Catholic lady
around the world who have legitimate
questions and it I hope that vegan Oh
second letter is a sign that the Pope
and other bishops can't remain silent
forever silence is not going to help us
root out the evil that is existing in
the bureaucracy of the church right and
the way the mainstream liberal media
covers this is so ironic because on one
hand they're telling us it doesn't
matter if dr. Christine velocity for it
has any evidence any proof of her
allegations we must believe the
allegations we don't need to look for
corroboration or documentation we'll
just believed her yet on the other hand
we have Pope Francis here and his
accuser his accuser Archbishop Vigano
says there is documentation you don't
have to take my word for it look at the
documents for yourself not only do they
not believe him he's the accuser
shouldn't we believe the accusers those
are the rules
not only did we not believe the accuser
they're not even willing to look for
corroboration they're not willing to
look for evidence and look for proof
they only they choose sides not based
off of justice they choose sides based
on their political agenda I think that's
evil it's so despicably partisan and you
see I mean this is the New York Times
par excellence is pretending to believe
all women but they don't believe the
prosecutor from the Senate Judiciary
Committee that woman who says that Fords
testimony falls apart they say believe
all of the accusers and yet they don't
believe Archbishop viga know who is
exposing incredibly abuses within the
church they won't believe him now you've
got the the New York Times defending
sexual abuse in the Catholic Church it's
pretty
and what it means by the way is politics
makes strange bedfellows it means that
now the Catholic lady are going to have
to rely on civil authorities on
attorneys general in states from coast
to coast
to try to open up these books and figure
out what abuses are going on because at
the moment the the press is complicit
with the abuse undertaken by bishops